So you remember generative
versus discriminative?
So generative,
I build a model of each class, and
then I compare it against all of them.
Discriminative, I build the model of
the boundary between the classes.
So we've talked a bunch about
building some discriminative ones,
let's talk again about
building generative.
How much you build
a reasonable generative model
of each class of action?
Okay.
Remember one of the reasons we might
want generative models we might
not have a whole lot of examples.
So a simple thing you might do is,
you've got a Hu-moment features space
and we've got seven things applied
to two images so we get 14 numbers.
So you could use some sort of Gaussian
or maybe it's a Gaussian with diagonal
covariance so that you don't have to
worry about having too many points.
And you might use a small number of
multiple mixture of Gaussians, but
the idea is you would build a model,
a Gaussian model,
for each of those classes.
And then what you'll do is
you'll compare the likelihoods.
You remember the likelihood was
probability of the data given the model.
Right so, I build all the models
then when the new data comes in I
evaluate the probability of the data.
Then if I have a prior,
then what I'm going to do is
I'm going to use Bayes rule.
That's what it says here.
That basically says I take my
likelihood, I multiply that by the prior
of my model and that's proportional
to my, to my total posterior.
If I don't have a prior,
I might just select whichever
one has the highest likelihood.
And by the way, if I don't have
enough data to even build some
reasonable model of the densities.
I might just use something
like nearest neighbor.
So, the nice thing that we have is
that mo, the motion energy images,
motion history images, they're
sort of little global descriptors.
And the way you do this is you're
going to collect these statistics on
these global descriptors in
order to do the recognition.
One of the things that might
be a little less obvious is
you can't actually recognize
the action till it's done.
Right, so, I have this description
that goes back in time so
if I'm watching a person sit down,
when their done sitting down,
I now have that chunk of data that
represents them sitting down.
Most activity recognition these days,
there's not a lot of focus on doing
online recognition that as as
you're watching something happen.
The idea of, is that they have
the whole sequence to begin with.
But if you're actually are worried about
recognizing it as it happens, this idea
that I can't recognize something till
it's totally done can be somewhat
concerning and you have to think
about how you might deal with that.